a director of photography killed movie
director injured after alec baldwin
discharged prop firearm on movie set cnn
story a film crew member has that and
another one has been injured
as he uh
discharged a prop gun in new mexico
thursday director photography
uh helena hutchins 42 was transported to
the hospital helicopter and pronounced
dead by medical personnel at the
university of new mexico hospital tragic
event director joel souza 48 years old
was transported to uh
christus saint vincent regional medical
center by ambulance uh for care rust in
a is a western film set in 1880 that
stars baldwin travis fimmel
and jensen echoes
echoes is what the uh
movie is about now i want to tell you
about the story with uh what alan
dershowitz said is the alec baldwin
shooting a homicide this is alan
dershowitz for msn the evidence is
currently unclear as to how to how a
real gun
would real projectile was handed to
baldwin allegedly with an assurance that
it was a cold gun such a verbal
assurance does not come close to
satisfying
what should be the failsafe standards
regardless of what the investigation
reveals it seems clear that the
preventable negligence contributed to
the death based on prior cases it should
have been crystal clear that no gun or
projectile capable of being fired should
have been on the set or anywhere near
baldwin and any other actors according
to numerous newspapers reported film
productions still often use real guns
loaded with blanks accordingly
uh these involve actual gun powder and a
cartridge that can provide a realistic
looking flame and spark burns and other
minor injuries are common but serious
injuries are death and death are unusual
it is likely that that the killing of
helena hutchins could constitute a
homicide that is a criminal killing
their remaining questions are who might
be criminal responsible for the killing
and what degree homicide fits the
evidence so having said that i'm gonna
go to you first what are your thoughts
about this
uh look i think obviously the biggest
question is
will
alec baldwin
go to jail for this will he be charged
with you know uh killing somebody
well look i think um
number one that's just what a sad
situation are you kidding me just that
you're on a movie set you don't think
anything other than you imagine just
coming to work today and hey everyone
get your set ready bang
okay so i think she was married she had
a young son um and alec baldwin gave a
heartfelt response to the family
uh there was a the director apparently
shot as well i don't know if it was the
same bullet shoulder yeah okay
um
you asked the question what's going to
happen to alec baldwin i don't think
anything whatsoever is going to happen
to alec baldwin as far as
um
you know being charged with anything
being sentenced to anything i think
you know look look at the evidence
that's happened here he was quote
unquote given a cold gun i think the
biggest question here is what the hell
was going on on that set
you know they said that the assistant
director had previously fought was fired
because of uh multiple gun incidents on
a set that he was on um
why is there a real gun on set i mean
we're making movies here we're making
fake stories but we have real guns on
set so i think they use real guns but
blanks they put blankets okay so why are
real bullets sometimes they use real
guns though do they really absolutely
wow sometimes they use real guns and
they were also saying that the gun had
misfired earlier on three times it
missed fire
there's been and i remember being a kid
this was probably in the early 90s i i
don't know the year maybe like 95.
but i remember an incident like this
happened i was in complete disbelief
and who was that person brandon lee
brandon lee you know where it was his
son where was it it was at ymca where i
was working out at 1995 out of here
that's the ymca i worked out at in what
year 95 yeah that's the wine sale would
go in glendale california right off of
harvard yes by rafi's place it's it's
it's like it's a 30-second walk from
rafi's place that's why it was all over
the place brandon lee when he got shot
you literally weren't even born that no
okay i think you were just born yeah 95.
i'm just born and uh but i remember that
happening i'm thinking whole
this is this a fake story yeah this is
this is pre
you know fake news and yeah
there's theories behind it that story
bruce lee's son was filming i think the
movie was called the crow
and an accidental fire farm went off and
brandon lee was killed like holy [ __ ]
bruce lee's son so there is a case
example of this i'd like to see what
happened in that incident i have the
answer okay ruled in the xml death by
prop gun on movie sex okay and then was
anybody charged no charges no charges i
think that's gonna be the same way yeah
look i don't think look do you think
look i know that this is not to be funny
or humorous but what is where's uh alec
baldwin made himself famous re famous
again over the last few years playing
trump
and one of trump's famous line is i
could go shoot somebody on fifth avenue
i won't lose any uh supporters so
look the analogy there is i think
he feels horrible like alex whether he's
charged with something or not which i
don't think he will be
alex baldwin has killed someone murdered
someone right and he's got to be filming
the girl alec baldwin yeah alec baldwin
and um
just a tragic situation but i don't
think he's going to be charged
your thoughts
well everybody keeps bringing up the old
tweet of his from 2017 quote i wonder
how it must feel to wrongfully kill
someone and uh now he knows um you know
it's sad man it's really sad but at the
same time it's not so baldwin was just
an actor right but he's also a producer
for the film so he bears some
responsibility in that the the uh the
armorer for the film was not qualified
she was like 24 years old uh and she
said something like i don't know what
i'm doing i've not done this before
right now i'm talking about the young
girl yeah yeah she had previously given
a gun to a child on set she didn't know
how to load the blanks
by the way you know i'm not even you
know this is a nice opportunity for our
good friend jared hutchinson she should
get in there and start doing stuff with
hollywood that's a good point well and
alec baldwin could have gone to terran
tactical in arizona or california it's
where all the stars train what is it
john berthold from uh the walking dead
yeah the punisher he's all out there all
the time he could have trained with the
weapons for a week you do a week's worth
of gun safety and you're this probably
doesn't happen or not to mention you
mentioned the will smith the clip
yesterday about the fact that one guy
points the gun and he says hey gun
safety is yeah
what's the first thing you do with a gun
when you're handed it you watch somebody
pull the mag out uh
run the chamber three or four times make
sure it's empty you watch them do that
and then you're given the gun and you do
the same thing you pull the clip out and
you run the chamber three four times
make sure it's unloaded i mean this is
it seems like it's common sense but
obviously it's come on tyler you're a
texas guy yeah i assume you've dealt
with guns before just the way you're
talking i mean uh just like once or
twice like that's it yeah i mean not as
much as probably i would like to you
know i'd like to go shoot more but i
really have it and it's everybody i know
every time i've seen a gun held you give
it to somebody you watch them pull the
clip out run the chamber three four
times and you do the exact same thing
and there's two rules you don't point a
gun at anything you're not ready to kill
and you don't put your finger on the
trigger unless you're ready to shoot now
they're saying he was doing you know the
pull out the the crossfire i think is
what it was called
you know so baldwin was baldwin was yes
this is an old western movie okay you
got your gun license from jarrah yeah
okay and no i think i also think it's
one of those trust but verify i mean if
i'm pointing something at someone i want
to make sure myself it's a matter
especially when there's a lot of people
there's been misfires on the set earlier
people are complaining about poor
conditions whatever the whole crew
walked off yeah that's the part that's
the part that people don't know the the
film crew
complained of unsafe working working
conditions prop gun misfire multiple
times before the this is daily while
wire story a group of camera crew
workers walked off the set
of russ to protest working conditions
hours before
this is literally
hours before alec baldwin who was
starring that's crazy in and producing
the western fatally shot one crew member
six members of the camera crew walked up
to set thursday morning after
days of complaining at long hours and
low pay members of crew were uh driving
to the set at bonanza creek ranch near
santa fe new mexico every morning from
albuquerque a roughly 50-mile trip
despite being promised hotel rooms in
santa fe corners were being cut and they
brought in non-union people so they
could continue shooting one person with
knowledge of the situation said they
also added that the prop gun that
baldwin killed hutchins would had uh
already misfired several times during
shooting so this isn't like this is the
part where it gets a little bit tricky
yeah cause it's not it's not just in one
time accident like if it's misfired
multiple times you kind of know okay
this this gun isn't as reliable this is
the definition double triple quadruple
verify here definition of when there's
smoke there's fire clearly there was
incident
here i'll give you an idea we did mafia
states of america right and we're on the
set and we're shooting we're going
through everything that we're doing you
know we hired a nurse you know we spent
four thousand dollars on the nurse that
was there how many times did we use her
zero not one time we had a nurse at the
location because it was an undisclosed
location to make sure people were safe
she sat there and she said you know i
have nothing to do i said ma'am you know
i appreciate you just being here because
if something happens we just want to
make sure we're ready because exactly it
could get ugly the situation that we
have with michael francis and sammy
we're just trying to be protected and
this is not a big budget we're not this
is not a 10 million dollar budget
hollywood movie it's a half a million
dollar budget we're talking about so
the point with something like this
the point with something like this is
you know
here's if i have a conversation with my
son tico okay
and
he makes a mistake that a five-year-old
makes yeah and he's done it seven times
and he does it again i say you know
better yeah you can't use that execute
you could use it at five you can't use
it at nine right i had a conversation
with one of our guys yesterday
and one of my favorite guys favorite
guys that i do business with i said
listen
there's one thing you're not you're not
stupid you're one of the smartest guys i
know okay yeah so when you have a
reputation of being very smart guess
what you can't ever play mistakes
you can't like you can't play dumb you
yeah you try to play it okay you like
that out but you can't play dumb okay so
what's what's the moral of the story the
moral of the story is this
we're not talking about a first-time
actor no we're not talking about a d a c
or a b or that guy you're talking about
alec baldwin and you're talking about a
guy
that you said the whole trump thing that
was going on four years
he mocked everything that you know if
there's if this was the other way around
so let's flip this and let's just say
because this is the best way to always
find out how these things work if this
happened to clint eastwood what happens
people are going to say i think there's
no issues yeah you've been on for a
while you're freaking dirty harry i mean
but what i'm trying to say is
i'm not putting it with that part let me
give you another one this happens to mel
gibson what do people say if mel gibson
did this if this happened on mel gibson
what happens to mel gibson he'd be trash
what would happen to mel gibson today
are you saying that because like listen
this isn't your rookie year you've been
on the block for 40 years this is this
is this is the part with politics that's
stay consistent yeah if somebody i had
the guy from babylon be here yesterday
set dylan who's an absolute start of a
guy and he's a christian guy right and
one of the main their biggest story they
ever did is a story where one of their
biggest story they did is
they said the
donald trump this is a satire website
like the onion except for the
conservative side not the left is on the
left side so they got you know they got
35 million visitors on a monthly basis
they got 34 000 monthly they got
subscribers that people pay
one of their stories they do this is a
christian based
you know satire website the article said
donald trump says uh
you know i have done more for
christianity than jesus himself okay
this is the story and it goes viral it
gets shared three and a half million
times not liked not
shared three and a half million times he
text me this morning he texted me this
morning to
share with me the article david i'm
gonna try to text this to you
uh for you to share this this this story
just came about he says pat this is not
a joke
donald trump just said the following
thing okay this was it two days ago
three days ago donald trump said this
month nobody has done more for
christianity or evangelicals or for
religion itself than i said this that's
a true story this is a true quote from
trump what he said right okay well he
has but but but the point is the point
is i want to share this with you uh
david do i have your number or no david
uh
uh i just send it to you just put it up
so people can't see it
so here's the question where i'm going
with the story okay
stay consistent yeah if this was mel
gibson would you have played the same
position you played msnbc cnn and all
the late night shows that are defending
alec because to me
if if it was a male if it was a clint if
it was even throw vince vaughn or
libertarian in there how would you have
handled this would you have come after
him i don't know i'm not telling you yes
or no all i'm saying is i don't know do
you see them they're playing politics
with this they're they're doing whatever
they can to put the blame
on the the producer and the set not on
alec what they don't realize is the fact
that he is one of the producers so this
is a responsibility on
you being the producer so it's a it's
not a it's not a simple situation i just
came here i acted and we left what
happened before the complaints unsafe
environment all of these things if the
attorney on the other side is arguing
they're going to use this okay and and
then forget about the guys on the other
side that are going to mock him for what
he said in 2017 yeah and he uses words
again so so i'm sorry you this is karma
catching up as well a little bit if you
play that card you have to be ready that
this is going to catch what's the
biggest thing i say about trump he keeps
creating unnecessary enemies i'm sorry
you did this to yourself alec and now
you're going to get some of it because
you kept joking about this now you did
this you're going to be held accountable
for it now the question do i really
think he's hurt
do i think this really messed with him
for him killing a crew member what do
you think absolutely emotionally yes
absolutely
there is no question about it i fully
believe the guy is devastated with the
fact that this took place and i don't
even think it's devastated from the
standpoint oh babe am i going to go to
jail like you're talking to a girl i
really think he's hurt i really think
he's mourning i really think he's
struggling with it but at the same time
we have law order we have justice okay
in the the point you made yesterday that
uh i don't know if you know when you
talk about a guy like this an a-lister
nothing's gonna happen to the guy with
an a-lister i actually agree with you
yeah okay we're on the same page
i think uh you know this has happened
three times there was another guy in the
80s that this happened to 24 year old
stutt actor that was coming up and they
shot him as well i don't know the name
he wasn't a big name it was before our
era in the 80s when this happened we'll
see what's going to happen here but if a
dershowitz is saying
you're going to be held accountable for
this there should be he's saying
someone's going to be held accountable
but he's a producer obviously he's a
producer
so if you were being too cheap to bring
somebody like they were interviewing a
guy that's a former uh fbi guy and what
he does today he gets hired to sit in
sets and making sure everything is safe
you're supposed to do that production
okay so he said every time before gun
goes somebody looks and says okay boom
boom boom here you go good that's their
job quality control if you don't have
that guy then the liability is on you
for not wanting to have that guy so who
is the person who's the executive
producer they're going to go to that so
i i think it's not going to be a pretty
sight but and i also think that when
when you have movie sets where you're
cutting a little bit on costs here or
there like you kind of get away with it
at the time but when when [ __ ] like this
happens or accidents happen yeah
everything is going to be scrutinized
and then it's just going to be blown up
too here's what's such a bigger one
here's what sucks about this here's what
sucks about this for the creative that i
just thought about so imagine the
creative that can't afford to pay alec
the money that they want to pay him yeah
and let's just say they're trying to get
a guy just to just come and do a cameo
or just come and do something basic
here's a role i want you to play dude
the standards for what's going to happen
with movies going forward is going to go
to a whole different level here's the
other thing that's probably going to
happen as well incidents like this with
the current climate that we have
sag
is going to over regulate like never
before the cost of what it's going to be
required to have on every single set
just went to the roof with this so the
small business owner creative is sitting
there saying freaking a expenses
probably just went up 10 20 percent and
we can't even afford it but we got to do
it now no you can't play a game at that
point no you can't it doesn't have to be
a cost thing it's a competence thing if
you just you don't have to hire somebody
that's expensive to have someone that's
competent you just have to to vet them
and do your research and put the proper
systems in place you don't have to spend
a ton of money to do this you're right
as this gets scrutinized you realize
that there were multiple failures at
every angle the 911 call the woman that
called in said somebody's been shot
turned and was talking to a colleague
while she was on the phone and said that
the assistant director had just yelled
at her at lunch
by the way right this whole this whole
movie was just a cluster and as it gets
scrutinized you realize that it wasn't
just the uh the armor it was failures at
multiple points and you know it could
have been prevented which is really what
oscar just said something he gave five
bucks thank you oscar he said if you if
you handle a real firearm you're 100
responsible to ensure that there's no
round in the chamber capable of firing
your projectile
uh involuntary or not that's involuntary
manslaughter is what oscar calls it
that's that's that's the firearm world
fully complies by that that's the rules
treat every gun loaded yeah treat every
gun as a team but i mean to circle back
to your point there was a case example
this exact situation and there was
nothing there was no legal charges that
was held accountable for that no not at
that point look like you brought up a
very good point with the sag stuff very
good point it says here in the daily
wire
um corners were being cut and they
brought in non-union people so they can
continue shooting so i think you're
you're spot on that they're gonna yeah
but this is gonna hurt the creative i'm
not supportive especially
i don't like that but unfortunately it
is
unfortunately liz like you know when i
was a hummer mechanic and
you would work on the truck
and that's what i did and you know
he was an e6 at fort campbell kentucky
we had a great time together we don't
know where you are we want to find you i
would talk so much [ __ ] to him as an e4
and he would talk [ __ ] back the coolest
cat on campus was him we had a good
community anyways so i would go there
and i'm like dude why are there so many
warning signs
warning warning warren says because some
idiot put his finger there and he's cut
his finger off
because something so it was like 75
warning signs so the military's finally
to protect ourselves
they just warning themselves out by
putting it all over the place right to
say okay we just don't want to deal with
this
i think something like this what what
what what sometimes like you know we
would do a video we would edit and
somebody doesn't do acoustic obviously
it's never happened here before it's
never happened here before with the
and it's just a very peaceful
environment but
i would always come back and i would say
who did the checklist yeah why what are
you laughing i look at david's lap right
why are you laughing david huh yeah okay
got it so yeah i gotta go qc something
we won't do that we would do the test to
see did you check this did you check
this did you check this did you check
this
i don't know i think this is a not a
rookie uh uh group that there uh it
looks like it's not a rookie group that
could have checked it anyways i think
before we move on i think bottom line is
this family is going to walk away with a
civil lawsuit and they're going to get
millions of dollars right listen man the
family
rightfully so at this point of the game
bro they're just sitting there like
they're missing a person to die this way
i mean come on you know there's ways to
go this is not a way you want to lose
somebody you love and it's so unexpected
you know it's not like the husband was
married to a police officer she was a
director a cinematographer on a movie
set it's like goodness gracious yeah
listen condolences goes out to that
entire family nothing anybody says is
going to replace the pain but
our prayers are with you